Hi everyone, in this lesson we're going to go ahead and take a look at some of the debugging
tools for Niagara as well as some things to consider.
So let's get started.
One of the tools that we have at our disposal is you'll see at the top if you double click
your effect, a button called performance.
Performance will give us a readout in milliseconds on how each one of the modules that we've created
is performing.
This can be pretty handy to be able to track where you might have some stalls if you've
made a lot of like really complicated things and they're all starting to pile up or several
different type of effects embedded in your overall effect.
Things could cost if you start to put too much at one particular effect.
So this helps you track that and see how things are performing and how their playback is doing.
Let's go and jump into Unreal and take a peek.
So here in Unreal we'll see that we have a performance button.
I'm going to go ahead and click on that.
Now this performance button and you'll see the numbers.
If you can't see them a little pro tip here, I can hit control and do the wheel mouse.
You can actually see these in percentage wise how much they're taking up in our scene.
You'll see an average millisecond calculation on the top there and you'll be able to actually
see what they're doing.
And again, you'll see it here.
It says this shows the module runtime cost in percent.
So your overall percentages in here you can track and you can see, well, man, this effect
is really heavy in this area.
This effect is overall I could probably do to the milliseconds that we have going on.
Maybe slow some things down.
Maybe have too much in here.
Have a fluid within a fluid.
One thing I do want to point out though, when you are using fluids, they are pretty heavy
because they are in a GPU effect and you'll see GPU is on here and I'll be referencing
GPU back and forth.
Now we do have Niagara classes.
This isn't a Niagara class, but this talks about how to control your environment and
optimize things accordingly.
So if you want to dive more into Niagara, feel free to do so.
But keep in mind, fluids are expensive by nature and sometimes they may not refresh
like you want.
You can simply just hit pause in the playback and run it again or you could select it and
sometimes it pops back into view.
Certain gas fluids may have a little bit of a refresh issue, but overall, especially if
you're pairing them with other effects like maybe there's a gas nested within another
effect.
So these are just things to consider when working with your effects overall.
You'll see the three dot button here right next to the performance button.
You'll be able to pull down and see the GPU profiling, display average, display maximum
if we turn that on, and you'll also see display relative values as well as display absolute
values.
So you have a bit of options here.
Another tool we have for debugging is the literal debug tool.
Now we'll break down a few other aspects of it too.
It is evolving, getting better, stronger, faster, but we're going to be looking at some of the
primary tools that we can use for optimization.
To be able to activate it, you can go to three different areas.
One, you can go into the details of that effect if you're selecting that in your editor.
Two, you can go to the tools pull down menu and go to debug and go to Niagara debugger.
And three, if you go into your effect itself and double click it, you'll be able to see
debug right next to that performance button nearby.
Let's go ahead and jump into Unreal and take a look at a few things.
So if I want to, I can run the performance in here showing my overall what's going on
with our effect and those percentages.
And I can also run the debug at the same time if I wish.
But I'm going to save a little bit of overhead and I'm going to turn that performance off.
Now that performance is not dependent upon whether we're playing in the viewer here.
We can actually hit pause and you'll see your percentages still running.
So I'm going to go and click on performance and turn that off.
I'm going to go and click on that debug here and you'll see it says debug hut.
You also have the option to look at the FX outliner, which we'll look at later.
And there's also an attribute spreadsheet.
Let's go ahead and take a look at the debug hut.
Now when we open up this debug hug, like I said before, you can get to it two different
ways, three different ways.
So we have tools, debug, now agro debugger, or selecting the effect in your environment.
You can simply just click on debug.
You can also capture some data, which is kind of connected, which you can also do with the
FX outliner.
Let's go and take a look at this debugger.
Now in the debugger, we want to be able to turn on our debug, HUD enabled.
There should be on by default.
You also want to turn on your debug, HUD rendering enabled.
This will give you some text, but also it will show you your overall little outline here
that we have for a scene.
We want to be able to actually see our little bounce.
This is important and isn't always on by default, but you can actually help that by clicking
this on.
You'll see it'll actually turn on for us.
So we also want to have a validate system simulation data buffers.
You can turn that on.
But these are optional.
You don't necessarily have to have all these on, such as validate particle data buffers,
validate particle system simulation data buffers, as well as validate log errors.
This is just a little secondary checkbox that allows you to double check your work and see
if things are doing what their intentions are.
So I'm going to go and turn these off for now.
We should be okay without them, but the options are there.
At any time you're unsure what something does, simply float over that effect and Unreal will
give you some pro tips.
These are very helpful.
These do have impact on performance.
I do want to mention that.
So note to self.
We have a debug overview enabled.
Turn that on.
And this will give us an overlay of what's going on in milliseconds for that particular
effect.
You'll also see include cascade.
So if you're grabbing something from the marketplace, that's a bit older and includes cascade.
You can do so.
But there's a Python script you can use to be able to convert those cascades into Niagara.
You have to just turn it on into your plugins.
But keep in mind when you do that, there's some editing that may be involved.
So let's go ahead and take a look at the debug overview mode.
You'll see we have GPU compute performance in here.
But by default, we can have the overview here.
And it shows us our total particles that were pushing.
Now it also shows us our memory.
And it also shows us our total emitters here.
I'll pulse my cursor so you can actually see where I'm at.
We can go over here too and choose scalability.
This will give us another overview, looking at all the content that we have going on.
Next we can do performance.
And again, this will show us the data that we need.
It'll show us what's going on on an average RT and also our general playback here in milliseconds
and also what we're pushing.
Again, you'll see the game thread, max on this particular one, and game thread average here.
And we've talked about game thread in previous classes.
Next we can go in here and choose performance graph.
Now this performance graph is going to give us a readout and show us where things are
spiking in here.
And these tools are really helpful, especially if you have a lot of effects in the scene.
So you've got to keep that in mind.
Also note to self, if you have fluids, fluids are a bit more expensive.
For again, they are GPU, they're running some GPU processes here.
And the higher or the more advanced they are and lots of different effects nested inside
of them, you've got to keep in mind that what they're going to cost, especially with several.
We can then choose also GPU compute performance again.
Go back to where we were.
And it gives us a big overlay.
Let me move this down so you can see it here and shows our average instances, average use
here or US, I should say, and max US.
Now you'll look at this in context.
You can see them all categorized here.
So we have compute curl, scattered particles, pre-sim velocity, sourcing.
So it's kind of peeling back the onion of all the effects that were working and some
of the modules that we have active within our effect.
As you look in the menu, as we scroll down, you have several options for viewing as well
as you'll be able to change some of the positioning and the font.
You'll see there's a font control here.
And if we scroll down even more, we can actually see there's a debug filter.
You can actually choose what system you're looking at.
Simply what I like to do is just deselect it, select it and then run the debug again.
Otherwise, if you load that filter, make sure you're not confused on what you have in place.
And that can happen, especially if you're working late at night.
But I like to simply just click and re-click again.
And it's pretty easy to do so.
You'll see there's a debug system here where you actually can look at verbose and just
gives you a little bit more information.
You'll see I got verbose here on.
We'll just do basic on this one if you want to basic.
And it's just looking at the system overall.
So you have a little bit of quality control in here too.
So if I went in here, you'll see there's system attributes.
If I hit a plus here, I'll be able to select what I want here.
Do I want to, let's go and open this up here, go and add an array for this system attribute.
And let me show you what I mean.
If I typed in system, it's basically like a tag area.
This would actually match all system processes to that particular region.
So it's almost like adding another slot in here and you'll see it real give you a quick
rundown for that.
So there's some advanced stuff and stuff you may not even touch.
I rarely will touch this one because I know that I don't really need it.
Everything that I try to build, I try to build clean in the system itself.
You'll also see that you have a font control, like we said before, but even here you can
move it and shift it if you needed to.
You'll notice there's debug particles here where actually we have a few more things we
can do such as there's tech more text options.
You can actually show your particle index if you need to.
There's quite a bit that we can play with.
It's really up to you.
And again, it's like a case by case.
I don't want to get too much into buttonology, but I want to talk mainly on the stuff that
I would be playing with and working with.
You'll see there's a perf overview here.
We can actually can control our preferences here for reporting your frames and you're also
samples mode, your frame total if you want to take a look at that.
And we also, if we scroll down just a little bit more, you can control the color of the
overall kind of testing of your look and feel for your object here.
And also, let me see here.
You'll also see there's a show global budget info right here.
And you'll see that pop up towards the bottom.
And let's go and turn this off for now.
So if we scroll up a little bit, you'll notice we also have an area called particle attributes.
This is under the debug particles.
Now I can add systems in here if I wanted to, but this is not typical for me personally.
I like to do it where I can track it a little bit better within the effect itself.
Again, let's go ahead and look at a quick review here at the interface.
We have Niagara debugger panel.
We have the playback options.
And we have the debugger tabs.
Each one of these are set up so that you can control the speed if you wanted to.
And take a look what you need to.
Now, when I say take a look, we want to focus mainly on the debug HUD and the FX Outliner.
Performance session browser and debug spawn are all experimental and they may not perform
exactly like you want.
So the main ones you want to focus on are these two, the debug HUD and the FX Outliner.
They're a bit more stable right now in their current version.
So just keep that in mind.
Again, key points I want to iterate here is again, we have the debug HUD enabled and
also the debug overview enabled.
This will give us what we need to be able to bring things onto the screen.
And again, under debug overview, you can analyze visually the output such as the GPU compute
performance and the overall performance.
Let's go and take a look at some things we can do on screen, such as look at our particle
perf.
This is basically looking at what's going on under the hood and how the frames per second
and the averages are working in our scene.
So what we'll do here is close the debugger.
With that on or with that off, I should say, you'll see that stuff that we had on screen
go away.
Let's go to our stats and in our stats, we'll look at engine and we'll look at the particle
preferences here.
Again, this is going to give us an overlay on our screen.
Now for running some problems, you can squeeze in your menus a bit.
You can actually see those full run of those numbers and see how things are performing
with our frames in our scene.
Another one we can run under stat Niagara, we can turn on Niagara baselines.
Let's do that.
So let's do that same thing.
We'll go under stat Niagara and Niagara baselines.
Now if it doesn't turn on automatically, just move your camera a little bit and it should
show up.
It sometimes is a little bit refreshed.
There it goes.
It's popped in and it's now decided to give us our information.
Now that particular system is used if you're going in here and it's a class for baseline
controllers and these can be or are responsible for spawning and manipulating the effect needed
for the baseline perf tests.
Now if you're a little bit more into programming to effects, you would understand where that
might be needed.
Now we're not going to jump into that.
I'm not going to run you through Python, Gambit here or a bit of C++ but overall you
can use these as a comparable if you turn them on on your screen.
And you'll notice we don't have anything right now to compare things to.
Another way to optimize your scene is to go in here and if your effect doesn't need to
move around, you can turn off require current frame data.
So this can save a little bit of overhead.
But again, if your effect doesn't need to move, you can turn this off.
This can help a little bit of the overall, especially if you have several that are kind
of complicated, but they're not really going to move.
There's no that extra calculation isn't really needed.
Now Unreal in aggregate slimmer, faster, stronger.
So and your machines may be really spot on.
You may not need to do this, but in other cases, it might help a little bit.
All of the stuff that we talked about so far in looking at the debug hub or HUD, I should
say, heads up display, you can actually run them via a console command.
And here are all the console commands that have listed in the lecture if you want to
reference them.
Obviously, you don't want to load them all.
You actually can do all of these through the menu, but these are options in here.
Here's a few more that can help you with playback if you wanted to control some of that.
So the first one here will play all simulations.
You'll see FX Niagara dot debug playback mode one will pause the simulation and FX Niagara
dot debug dot playback mode two will step single frames and then pause all simulations.
Now you can also do that within the Delta tick inside of the effect itself, but you
can also do it here through their playback mode.
FX dot Niagara dot debug playback rate.
You can also control that as well as FX dot Niagara debug playback rate 0.1.
If you want to run all simulations at half the speed.
So I'm not going to go through all of these, but these are all available to be able to
see and be able to tweak and edit things if you needed to.
If you wanted to check your speed, check your thread count and et cetera, as well as your budget.
That's it with this lecture.
In the next lecture, we're going to take a look at FX Outliner breakdown.